bonjour à tous aujourd'hui j'ai essayé
de vous répondre une question qui m'est
très souvent posé en commentaire depuis
l annonce de la sortie de l'iphone 8 l
iphone 8 plus est ce que les
utilisateurs d'iphone 7 et d'iphone
cette plus doivent changer
si oui pour quelles raisons et sinon
pour quelle raison alors qu'on va faire
dans cette vidéo c'est que on va faire
un comparatif sensiblement point par
point les mois les éléments les plus
importants entre l'iphone 7,7 plus et
8,8 plus et à la fin on fera un point
global pour voir si effectivement il ya
un intérêt oui ou non à changer de
smartphone
si vous ne connaissez pas je suis
monsieur heureux ma chaîne par deux
stratégies numériques pour vous aider à
aller plus loin dans votre vie numérique
en par le sida de stratégie youtube que
de tous les produits d' influence si
vous voulez avoir toujours plus de
bonnes infos et de bons plans pour
réussir votre vie numérique je vous
invite à vous abonner à la chaîne et
activer la cloche pour ne manquer aucune
publication
apple a annoncé il ya très très peu de
temps la sortie effectivement de trois
nouveaux iphone pour 2017
l'iphone 8 l'iphone 8 plus et l'iphone
10 iphone 10 pour l'instant on laisse de
côté ayant vraiment centré sur l'iphone
8 à l'iphone 8 plus si vous êtes un
possesseur de l'iphone c'est tout de
l'iphone cette plus est ce que ça vaut
le coup de changer oui ou non
et justement c'est une question qui est
très intéressante parce que si on les
regarde principalement déjà d'un point
de vue esthétique
au niveau des fonctionnalités et même au
niveau de l'iphone en lui-même les
différences sont pas forcément aux yeux
pourtant il y en a il existe des
différences sont plus guère aidé des
points de détail plutôt des écarts
monstrueux on va très bien entre
l'iphone 7,7 plus et l'iphone liste il
ya quand même une révolution entre le
ceds elle plus séduite c'est pas trop ça
alors on va regarder ensemble la plus
première chose qui ne change pas sorte
d'iphone c'est effectivement le tchad
vous serez sûr de 7,7 +88 plus le child
dit c'est exactement la même chose donc
de ce point de vue là ça ne fait pas la
différence
la caméra de cette fille c'est
exactement la même une cette méga pixels
avec une ouverture en 2.2 que ce soit
d'ailleurs sur un 7/7 plus soin 8,8 plus
c'est la même chose
la caméra arrière du iphone celle de
l'iphone 8 font toutes les deux 12
mégapixels avec une ouverture en 1.8
c'est pareil il n'y a pas de différence
significative de ce point de vue là
concernant l'iphone 5 plus et l'iphone
de 8 plus c'est aussi la même chose 12
mégapixels avec un objectif grand angle
qui est l'ouverture en 1.8 et un
téléobjectif avec une ouverture en 2.8
ça ne change pas c'est vraiment la même
chose entre les deux
dell le trou tonnes devraient pouvoir
faire la différence excusez moi pour mon
accent mais il devrait y avoir
effectivement une différence en allemand
entre 7,7 plus et 8,8 plus se regardent
purement les spécifications techniques
ça ne saute pas aux yeux donc je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il y ait une vraie différence
est que de ce point de vue là en tout
cas ça vaille le coup de changer de
votre smartphone
la différence va surtout se faire sur la
vidéo est sur un point précis c'est le
slow motion sur l'iphone 7 et cette
pluie je pouvait filmer en 4k en 30
images seconde
alors que sur l'iphone 8 et 8 plus vous
pouvez filmer en cas car on 30
images/seconde également en 60 images
seconde maintenant si vous filmer en
full hd en 1080p sur l'iphone cette es7
plus vous pouvez film effectivement 30
images/seconde 60 images secondes mais
également en 120 images par seconde par
contre sur l'iphone 8 et 8 plus vous
pouvez filmer en 30 images seconde 60
images/seconde 120 images seconde et en
240 images seconde
ça s'est vraiment bien pour avoir des
ralentis de qualité est vraiment faire
du slow motion purement et simplement
donc il ya une vraie différence se fait
là dessus si vous faites de la vidéo si
vous êtes vidéaste et vous filmer avec
votre iphone
si vous voulez vraiment avoir des effets
en slow motion il existe vraiment une
différence entre ces deux produits
alors les deux appareils ou une
certification ip67 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière
ce qui est surprenant aujourd'hui c'est
qu'apple ne sont pas partis sur une
certification ip68 alors que la plupart
des concurrents l'ont choisi alors qu'il
ya une petite différence en terme
d'immersion en termes de résistance sous
l'eau un stick à la poussière
alors effectivement le téléphone n'est
pas fait pour être utilisé sous l'eau
mais on comprend difficilement que sur
des produits premium et sur des produits
de ce prix là apple n'est pas cherché à
obtenir une certification ip68 l'iphone
cet essai de plus vous avez un
processeur à 10 fusionnent chipant
disque sur le 8 et 8 plus vous avez le à
bionic la vraie différence avait
effectivement la puissance le nouveau
processeur à 11 et donnait 25 ans en
plus rapide que le son prédécesseur le à
disent avoir maintenant dans vos
utilisations courantes
est-ce que vous allez vraiment sentir
une différence je n'en suis pas certain
d'y avoir effectivement une différence
en terme de calcul notamment lorsque
vous allez chercher à utiliser de la
réalité augmentée
et que vous retrouverez sur l'iphone 8 l
iphone 8 plus concernant votre
navigation je ne suis pas persuadé que
sur internet il ya une vraie différence
urticants l'ouverture vos applications
vous sentiez une nette différence
probablement un temps de chargement peut
plus rapide ouverture un peu plus rapide
mais vraiment sûr de la milliseconde
donc je suis pas nécessairement furetant
sur l'utilisation classique
il ya une vraie différence à noter que
l'iphone 7 est proposée en 32 gigas et
en 128 alors que l'iphone 8 et 8 plus
sont proposés en 128 giga et en 256 giga
il ya aussi une différence de prix mais
sans leur parle juste après ils ont tous
les quatre un écran lcd
si vous voulez duo l'aide il faudra
choisir l'iphone 10 sur l'iphone secte
et sur l'iphone 8 vous avez un écran 4,7
pouces avec une résolution de 1334 par
750 pixels à 326 ppp disent que sans les
phone 7 plus et 8 plus vous avez
également le même écran en 5 25 pouces
en 1920 par 1080 pixels à 420 p pays
donc du point de vue de l'écran ça ne
change pas écran lcd en tous les cas la
même résolution la même définition à
noter que l'iphone 8 et 8 plus sont
équipés du bluetooth 5.0 contre le
bluetooth 4.2 pour les modèles
précédents
le bluetooth 5.0 aujourd'hui c'est la
norme on comprend difficilement
également que apple sur son iphone 7 et
utiliser du bout du stade points 2 alors
qu'il ya des modèles qui sont quand même
plus ancien est sûre sur des concurrents
de table qui utilise du bluetooth 5.0
déjà depuis un petit moment
apple comble son retard d'ailleurs sur
pas mal de points par rapport à ce
téléphone ya effectivement des points
qui sont ingénieux et des points
d'évolution on le voit notamment sur la
réalité augmentée c'est des choses qui
qui deviennent vraiment intéressante et
sur lequel apple vraiment progresse
énormément mais voilà pas de révolution
énorme sur ce produit là autre point
intéressant et qui très très très peu
regardez c'est le das alors le das c'est
quoi c'est votre exposition aux ondes
iphone 8 un das de 1,36 le 8 plus de
0,99 le 7 1 38 et le 7 + 1 24 donc si on
doit comparer entre ces quatre modèles
c'est l'iphone 8 plus qui l'emportent
haut la main à noter que dans la gamme
actuelle des iphone c'est l'iphone est
ce qui a le plus petit das les nouveaux
modèles le 8 et
l'i phone 7 sont pas des très très bon
élève en termes de das la chaux nuitées
8 plus peuvent se recharger par
induction qui permettra de recharger
votre appareil à 50 % en seulement une
demi heure de charge ça c'est bien beau
dans la théorie sauf que en réalité les
iphone 8 et 8 plus ne sont pas vendus
avec le chargeur à induction
ils sont vendus avec le câble lightning
vous allez leur charge est donc
exactement de la même manière lorsque
vous rechargez votre iphone 7,7 plus
voir les modèles antérieurs
c'est problématique si vous voulez
puisque apple fait la promo il ya même
conceptualisé ce produit avec un dos en
verre pour pouvoir effectivement avoir
cette recharge rapide le vendre comme
pouvant effectivement se recharger par
induction
sauf que il n'est pas vendu avec le
chargeur et ça c'est vraiment dommage
si vous voulez l'acheter ça vous coûtera
60 4 euros 95 en plus ça fait râler
vous êtes quand même sur des produits
qui coûtent très cher on vous vend un
produit qui se recharge par induction et
lorsque vous l'achetez surprise il n'y a
pas d'indication il faut encore ajouter
quasiment 70 euros sur des produits de
cette gamme là c'est quand même très
très très très dommage
il ya aussi le air power qui va arriver
dans les temps à venir qui vous
permettra d'avoir une zone de recharge
beaucoup plus grande sur laquelle vous
pouvez recharger votre iphone votre
watch si comme moi vous espériez un
retour de la prise jack
il n'y en a pas vous êtes toujours un
adaptateur lightning prise jack qui vous
permettra de brancher un micro ou tous
les accessoires vous souhaitez avoir un
jack
la différence se fait également d'un
point de vue esthétique comme je vous
disais à l'instant la faune 8 et 8 plus
ont un dos en verre ce don enverra une
utilité elle permet une recharge à
l'induction
elle a néanmoins un aspect un peu
négatif c'est le poids l'iphone 8 et
l'iphone 8 plus ont un peu plus lourde
une vingtaine de grammes à peu près en
moyenne par rapport au modèle cet essai
de plus c'est pas énorme 20 grammes dans
votre poche
mais voilà il ya quand même une petite
différence là dessus par contre c'est
dos en verre sont vraiment vendu par
apple comme étant extrêmement résistant
on l'espère ça reste à voir
côté tarifs maintenant l'iphone 864 j
a kout 809 euros et en 256 giga 979
euros
si vous voulez passer sur le modèle un
peu plus grand avec le double capteur en
arrière vers l'iphone dit plus ça vous
coûtera pour le modèle en 64 giga 919
euros et sur le 256 giga 1089 euros ça
veut dire que si vous voulez acheter un
iphone 8 plus je vais faire le petit
calcul en direct vous allez voir un
iphone vite plus coûte 1000 89 euros si
vous voulez avoir de la recharge par
induction il faut rajouter 64 euros 95
ce qui vous fait un total à 1153 95
il faut savoir que l'iphone 10 dans sa
version 64 giga coûte 1000 159 euros
c'est à dire que vous avez 6 euros
d'écart si vous voulez l'iphone 8 plus
avec une recharge à induction la
question se pose réellement sur ce
modèle là avec un chargeur à induction
est ce que ça vaut le coup d'aller sur
un iphone 10 sans recharge à induction
mais ça coûte exactement le même prix
effectivement l'iphone 7 à diminuer prix
en 32 gigas écoute 639 euros en 128 giga
il coûte 700 49 euros
l'iphone cette plus quant à lui good 779
euros en 32 gigas et en 128 giga 889
euros
la question à se poser et si vous avez
un iphone 7,7 plus est ce que vous devez
switcher sur le 8,8 plus pour moi la
réponse est très claire c'est non
à moins que vous soyez un très très très
grand fan de la réalité augmentée vous
voulez absolument rechargé votre
téléphone dans votre voiture par exemple
qui n'avait besoin dans ces conditions
là sinon à mon sens ça ne sert
strictement à rien si maintenant vous
avez un téléphone intérieur si vous avez
1 5 à 5 cm un iphone 4 1 est ce que vous
voulez passer sur un iphone 8
là il ya un vrai sens moi j'ai ainsi
cesse vous voyez par exemple j'ai testé
la caméra j'ai pu filmer une vidéo je
sortirai très très bientôt avec l'iphone
il ya une vraie différence de caméras
puisque la caméra de l'iphone c'est
exactement la même que celle de l'iphone
si vous êtes sur un modèle qui est
ancien ça vaut le coup de le faire si
maintenant vous avez un iphone 7 et vous
poser la question du 8 allée directement
sur l'iphone d'ici là une vraie
évolution avec un écran oled avec du
bord à bord un déverrouillage avec les
failles saïdi enfin tout ça on en
reparlera probablement une prochaine
fois si vous avez un certain 7 plus à
mon sens ne passait pas sur l'iphone 8
vous perdriez de l'argent dites moi vous
ce que vous en pensez
est ce que cette vidéo vous a aidé à y
voir un peu plus clair dans vos choix
est ce que vous pensez si vous avez un
7/7 plus est ce que vous pensez quand
même changé pour un 8 8 plus est ce que
vous envisagez l'iphone ten dites moi
tout en commentaire
j'ai hâte de voir ça y est on en parle
ensemble je vous remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous invite à
vous abonner à la chaîne pour avoir
toujours plus d'informations sur votre
vie numérique et sur votre stratégie
numérique
si vous avez des questions vous pouvez
poster sur twitter @ monsieur heureux
avec le hashtag à ce monsieur groupe
quant à moi je vous dis à très bientôt
d'ici là portez vous bien
puis bonne chance pour une fois sur vos
iphone salut
[Musique]